on s'est aventuré à vous poser une
question toute bête mais en fait c'est
quoi ce petit chapeau vert sur certaines
bouteilles de vin geslin qu'une idée
probablement un rapport avec l'écologie
je ne sais pas aucune idée pour des
questions écologiques dont je pense que
je sais pas non je fais beaux voiliers
la capsule mais j'ai pas beaucoup et dr
elle est verte parce que ça serait
d'appellation d'origine et elle serait
bleus si c'était un pays où vous savez
ça alors je sais ça parce que je suis
cabistes ce petit chapeau ça s'appelle
le crd pour cap sur représentatif de
droit à chacun sa couleur vert pour les
aoc bleu pour les vins de table ou
encore orange pour les vins spéciaux et
sur chaque bouteille le même visage qui
s'affiche fièrement car marianne c'est
bien-être qui se trouve sur les capsules
des bouteilles de vin depuis 1960 à
l'époque il s'agissait pour les douanes
de vérifier simplement que ses droits
avaient bien été payée sauf que
quasiment cinquante ans plus tard ce
petit code couleur devrait devenir
facultatif de quoi créer un peu
d'inquiétude chez des vignerons dans un
territoire comme la bourgogne
nous on rayonne en a 84 cahier des
charges différents d'appellation c'est
plus de 110 appellation aujourd'hui la
crd avait le mérite de chapeauter
l'ensemble des appellations d'origine
contrôlée demain on ne sait pas si on va
pas nous imposer quelque chose à
l'appellation ça veut dire que là ce
serait beaucoup plus compliqué à gérer
pour les petites exploitations qu'on est
quoi ca pas toujours dans le sens de la
simplification pour les viticulteurs
place une supplication pour
l'administration
ce nouveau décret devrait prendre effet
d'ici un an à partir du 1er juin 2019